il ya des indices qui ne trompent pas
nous sommes bien en terre britannique
banksy mais ici le fish and chips se
déguste à l'ombre des palmiers et le
soleil brille toute la nuit voilà le
charme de gibraltar
c'est comme un petit bout d'angleterre
dans la méditerranée on ne se rend pas
compte de la chance qu'on a là une
enclave à l'extrême sud de l'andalousie
dont les anglais profitent depuis un peu
plus de trois siècles grâce à un traité
signé en 1713 avec l'espagne depuis les
deux cultures s'ils sont mélangés
nous avons notre propre langue locale le
iannitto qui combine de l'anglais et de
l'espagnol ça donne ça
un lieu hautement stratégique le seul
passage maritime entre la méditerranée
et l'atlantique
en face les côtes marocaines ne sont
qu'à 14 km le nom de gibraltar vient de
l'arabe jebal qui signifie la montagne
et c'est d'ici qu'on la voit le mieux se
détacher au dessus de la péninsule un
immense monolithe de calcaire de 426
mètres de haut et justement on va se
rendre au sommet
nous montons à bord d'un téléphérique
vue imprenable sur le détroit l'une des
routes commerciales les plus empruntées
au monde cent mille navire la traversent
chaque année
au sommet du rocher nous découvrons l'un
des symboles de gibraltar
une colonie d'environ 305 les seuls
macaques sauvage du continent européen
ça la terrifie je ne suis pas rassuré
site un sac à dos ils peuvent te le
piquer il ne faut pas oublier qu'ils
sont chez eux et que ce sont nous les
étrangers
ces primates sont à l'origine d'une
croyance populaire bien connu des
habitants la légende raconte que si les
singes disparaissent du rocher gibraltar
deviendra espagnol durant la seconde
guerre mondiale par superstition le
premier ministre churchill a fait venir
des singes d'afrique parce qu'il ne
restait plus que sept
gibraltar a aussi une face cachée
attention à la tête tito vit ici depuis
toujours nous nous enfonçons avec lui
dans les entrailles du rocher
un labyrinthe de pierre où nous serions
vite perdu sans notre guide
il y à 50 km de tunnel en fait il y a
plus de route à l'intérieur du rocher
que dehors durant la seconde guerre
mondiale ce dédale souterrain a été
utilisé par l'armée anglaise pour cacher
des hommes et du matériel
ici ils pouvaient se protéger des
bombardements tout été conçu pour
pouvoir accueillir seize mille soldats
avec des munitions de la nourriture et
de l'eau pour quatre mois mais
comment savoir monde à bien certaines
galeries sont aujourd'hui reconverti en
musée de la guerre
d'autres sont encore utilisés par
l'armée britannique mais celle-ci même
tito n'y a pas accès ils préfèrent nous
reconduire à l'air libre et voilà la fin
du monde et notre homme ne croit pas si
bien dire pour nous en rendre compte il
faut embarquer sur les eaux du détroit
et se laisser guider par angie
mais plus encore que la mythologie
grecque sa passion ce sont les dauphins
ce jour là elle en même un couple en mer
pour les observer on s'est marié il ya
juste deux jours
et le cadeau des jeunes époux ne s'est
pas fait attendre c'est génial d'être
aussi près je n'en avais jamais vu un
seul avant c'est juste magique
sur une péninsule d'à peine 7 kilomètres
carrés gibraltar est un petit monde en
soi au carrefour des maires et des
continents